okay perfect thanksgiving yeah so here's
a uh list of wonderful co-organizers
um adam clivens lugosi anchor maitre
presader govendra
swam and um
so in order to motivate sort of the
setting uh for this program
i'll just give some sort of uh high
level
uh motivation of the typical sort of
statistics problem that
we and sort of the rest of the world
wants to solve and so it's the highest
level one wants to estimate
a signal in random noise and this sort
of setting captures also
learning a model parameters of the model
given data and so forth
now the sort of basic features
of the setting are that the signal has
some structure maybe some combinatorial
structure
it could be some graph structure it
could be
a sparse vector it could be any of those
things
and there are other features of the
problem that describe the quality of the
data so it could be the amount of data
it could be
the strength of the signal and so forth
all right so um one wish is to solve
some sort of estimation problem
you know in some specific context and
the two basic sorts of resources
that one has in order to try to solve
such a problem are
one the data of course this is what we
have in front of us
from which we're trying to conclude an
answer
and the second is computation so
anything that we're going to do on the
data is going to require
some amount of computation and so if one
wants to understand what's a good
algorithm
what's an algorithm that's going to be
effective well the first question would
be how much data do i need
and this question has been studied in
mathematical statistics for a century
the title slide i don't know if you're
advancing them
i am oops well let's see
maybe there's a better way for me to
share the screen
we're seeing that
so
[Music]
you're only seeing the title slide this
is what you said right
now you can show the desktop and then do
this
that's it we're seeing the okay good so
good too perfect the generic generic
statistics problem signal plus noise or
estimate parameters of a machine
learning model
um and uh basic resources
data and computation so like i said
mathematical statistics
is concerned with how much data do we
need but it says nothing about
computational complexity
at the same time the field of
computational complexity has been
concerned with
how much computation do i need to solve
some problem
and says very little about the sorts of
practical
uh real-life machine learning and
statistics problems that we're faced
with
because those problems have data that is
benign in some sense and most of
computational complexity concerns
worst-case
uh worst case problems of course with
that said i mean there is
of course the field of average case
complexity and also cryptography studies
average case problems
but most of what's been done there
doesn't apply to the sort of statistics
problems that statisticians are faced
with
now what's intriguing is that these two
resources actually
interplay one with another and so these
problems can't be studied only from one
perspective
one actually needs to combine the two
perspectives in some way and so at the
high level that's what the aim of this
program is
is to understand how do these two
resources interplay
how much of each of them do i need
for each sort of problem that i'm
interested in
so i'll give a sort of a case study here
in this next slide
this case study is an example problem
for which
there is a pretty satisfactory
understanding and this understanding is
captured
by what's can be called a feasibility
diagram
and so on the vertical axis we have a
signal strength parameter
as we go up the signal gets weaker on
the horizontal axis
there's a parameter capturing the
sparsity of the signal you can think of
it generically
just something that's controlling the
combinatorial structure of the signal
that one wishes to recover
and over roughly a decade of intense
study by many many researchers
the following feasibility diagram has
emerged
and what it does at the highest level is
partitions the set of possible
the set of parameters of the problem
into three regions
one where the problem is just impossible
meaning it's impossible even with
infinite computational power there just
isn't enough signal
information is too weak there's an easy
regime
where an efficient algorithm often
linear time or
low low order polynomial can solve the
problem
and then there's a hard regime where
it's believed to be hard and there's
various forms of evidence indicating
that it's computationally hard
but it is feasible in principle if one
is willing to invest massive amounts of
computational
power and so this problem is pretty well
understood because there's this
kind of demarcation of every possible
parameter
into one of the three regimes and so
this is a success
of the of the field but the concern is
that this took a decade of work
by a lot of people and dozens of papers
on the topic
there are one minute many dozens of
problems
uh exhibit this sort of behavior
and so this motivates the question how
the world do we understand this
landscape
of problems and how do we understand
their computational feasibility
as a function of how much data we have
or vice versa how much
data do we need for computationally
efficient algorithms
the broad objectives of the field in a
nutshell are one
what is the amount of data that needs is
needed by computationally efficient
algorithms
two if we have notions of optimality
that are supported by item one then what
are those
optimal algorithms that achieve this
minimum
more broadly can we understand
relationships between problems as
opposed to setting problems in isolation
which is what's traditionally done
in uh in statistics and can we elicit
relationships between
classes of algorithms instead of just
applying every possible algorithm to
every
statistical problem we understand some
hierarchy of their power
and so the program will bring together
researchers from the disparate field
study these questions statistics
throughout computer science information
theory learning theory statistical
physics
to address these questions and uh
to that end there are several workshops
each targeting one of these main
objectives